what age do you think men and women Peak
on dating apps
I'm gonna say 22. for women for women
what do you guys think oh this one Asia
must be yeah 24th a month okay what do
you guys think for a man
I think it's later in life because
somebody doesn't look like 31 31
maybe like later 20s almost late 20s for
men
tell us
researchers determined that while men's
sexual desirability Peaks at 50.
women starts at 18. and falls from there
for online daters women Pika 18 while
men peak at 50.
that is I mean I'm for you when I'm good
with that
yeah I'm good without hitting your feet
better but I'm just and that's the thing
that's the whole thing that gets into
the the argument of
um
younger women like older men
facts and older men like younger women
and so but what happens to the women
that are in that older bracket they get
a bitter right because my checks they
get better right they need such eggs
because they see they see the younger
girls doing what they used to do and
then they demonize the older guys we're
going for younger women when those are
the women going for all the guys when
they were younger correct because when
you because everyone remembers like you
know when you're at school or college or
whatever yeah those girls that were at
College the guys that would roll up in
the the car in the astross
they will always go for the older guys
they always would and then what would
they tell you guys my entertainment
women have always liked older men but in
winter when it flips now and they start
to hit their Peak and they climb that's
when they start demonizing the men oh
well you guys are weird why can't you
finally go your own age right here for
younger girls yeah you was that girl
like 10 years ago why do you guys think
that women tend to shame men for having
standards
because they're old and bitter what do
you guys think I'm just curious like
because
so whenever whenever men have a standard
often and I'm not saying every woman
right but oftentimes women shame them
for having it so like we have the body
positivity movement right if guys I
don't like fat chicks
I've got to say I don't wanna I don't
want to date a single mother ah if they
say I don't want to date
ugly girls like anything that they say
they're shamed for
I think it's because we treat men like
trash
okay and we have too much High
expectation of how they should treat us
and what they should be doing for us and
this and the other but we don't hold
ourselves in the same regard I do think
that men don't get treated correctly I
think in certain cultures obviously I'm
from
um um from the black community I think
black women get treated black women can
sometimes treat black men like absolute
duh and then it's the same cycle you go
through you know someone who's got a lot
of baby fathers and then she has a son
and then she raises her son to be just
like the dad that she costs it doesn't
make sense like that but it's a very
deep like it's like obviously these are
deep issues that go into life that's
very interesting we talk about that
um when it comes to dating apps like the
the p on dating apps and the people that
at least the women that are least
desired on dating apps happen to be
black women
but do you think that's because sorry
because that when I for example when I
went on Tinder that time it was
saturated with white how you sit this
one out it was saturated with white men
so obviously it's like who's frequent in
these apps
is is that is that a cultural thing so
they were and there are there weren't
many black men on there so and I also
think that in society black women are
not desired why
foreign
apps the most desired woman is the Asian
women
on dating apps they're the ones that are
most desired Asian girls
kids they can cook better I I wonder if
you if I got left for an Asian chick I
would understand that Asian women I
would understand Asian women are most
desired black women release I think
because of white men are most desired
black men are creeping up there
but Asian men are least desired
Ness yeah I feel
social media
media what was portrayed as beautiful
and what has been put like thrown out
there if you look at like adverts when
we were younger and models and Etc it
was like the Slimmer white blonde Etc so
they weren't pushing through that
culture of having you know having black
women as as desired right and then I
think because of certain things within
Black Culture where
women have gone through certain
struggles and they've got you remember
we were talking before on the other
episode about like masculine energies or
right those energies there creates this
this thing where
the women are with strong independent X
Y and Z and men are not finding that
necessarily meant would you say that men
in general not just black not just white
not just Asian do not find a masculine
woman desirable
I think that men like to have that
element of they're looking after you so
women are nurturing but a man wants to
feel like he's able to take care of you
so if you if you're on a level where
it's like no I don't need you men like
to be needed so I I think that kind of
ties into here I think it's really sad
how black women have been treated and
Etc in terms of Attraction it's it's
sort of a Mad complicated issue I'm
mixed so the mixed experience is a
completely different experience as well
everyone has their own you were like you
don't count see that and do you know let
me tell you something
you ask a question yeah being
light-skinned is not always the easiest
thing either because people have sort of
it it was a trend right so it's a
relatively new thing if you look at like
when it was when people were able to
have Multicultural relationships it's
kind of a new generation so then it was
a fashion statement so you'd get women
who were like oh I want a light-skinned
child you're not thinking about all the
things that come with having you know a
child that is from a different world who
would say I want a light skin child
I've heard white girls say that right
okay I have yeah like because they think
that Designer babies yeah designer baby
but it's like it's not about that you
actually bring in another human into
this world yeah so it's like it's not
about what you know how melanated you
are but it's yeah
I have a question for you
um so what do you think about women
shaming men for not having standards
because it's interesting I feel like
you've changed your tune a little bit
since last year ah no not at all we're
just talking about something completely
different okay do you know what I mean
that that's it
um I I personally don't shame anyone for
having standards I don't mean standards
I think you your standards should
reflect how you carry yourself if I
don't drink and I was saying I want a
bloke that doesn't drink that's fair
enough if I was out every weekend
getting pissed and I was saying I don't
want to play I want I don't want to buy
the drinks in then it's a double
standard I think everyone should have
standards I don't see the point in that
so you disagree with women that shame
men for not anyone that is women men and
I know what that so like women women
I'll give you an example women were
shaming Leonardo DiCaprio for only
dating girls under 25. I do think that
is a bit suspect if I'm honest okay okay
you agree okay I think I think there's a
certain age Gap
and it's if it's a that things like that
people fall in love I'm not saying every
age Gap is weird I think if you're an
older bloke and you've got a habit of
going with younger girls and I I
personally think it's sexual preference
oh yeah I do because I think sometimes
there's um a power Dynamic what if it's
the same what if it's a woman going for
a younger oh 100 it's the same thing
it's like that or what if it's a what if
it's a beautiful woman going for a rich
guy
is she taking advantage of him but is he
only with her because she's beautiful so
it's the same thing isn't it right but
I'm sorry
eye candy yeah that's what I was saying
but like why why is one shamed and the
other isn't I I think I just said they
were both the same in it no I was I was
sad
for myself I'm saying if a beautiful
woman is with a rich man but you said
that one's okay no I was but I'd imagine
he's probably with her
because she's beautiful that's the way
it is isn't it like men like I think I
think we both want attractive Partners
yeah because everyone wants someone
they're attracted to Jesus that is what
it is that's just I know people say but
it's just it's just interesting because
you said that you don't shame anyone for
having standards but you kind of did
with oh with the eyes so that's a
different sort of that's a different
sort of make sure they're over 21. 21 to
25 I think that's
what so if a 50 year old started dating
the 21 year old you think that's all
right yeah not fair enough he wants to
fair enough if she's okay with it I
think at 21 you can make your own like
when I was 21 I could make that decision
I wouldn't do it why not me personally
as a 50 that that's two as a 41 year old
man I wouldn't date a 21 year old that's
just me personally would you find it
weird if one of your mates said do you
want to meet month ago I'm day in and in
water 21 year old I wouldn't find it
weird would you be a little not at all I
wouldn't find it weird why wouldn't you
do it because everyone's different once
ever once people are of age I'm like you
can do what the hell you want but I'm
just saying for I'm just saying for me
as an individual yeah yeah I couldn't
like I'm just like what do I have in
common with a 21 year old well I I I I
can't see it
but some 50 year olds just don't care no
right exactly exactly I don't
I don't he's hot exactly as many
as many talk and
we basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible